The US president.
Donald Trump has an idea that he won't
get off on how you determined link
continues to unleash his own world.
War in this case,
say commercial war against the rest of
the world
with a bank that everybody's stealing
from.
Well,
I respect China and I respect President
Xi,
but they've been killing us,
convinced that the United States is
being harmed and even Robert in its
trade relations.
In recent months,
Donald Trump has launched a tough
protectionist policy and as multiplied
tariffs from now on,
billions of dollars in imported products
by the United States will have to face
the heavy tariffs that this
administration has approved is
essentially the economic he revolutions
of by these American products or else
you're not a true patriot.
Welcome to the 1930s apparently.
The fact is that during July,
2018 new tariffs are going to come into
effect of no less than 25% on products
that the United States imports each year
from China,
which is worth about $50 billion.
By the way.
Additionally,
just a few months ago,
the White House place tariffs on Steel
Alemanian minium solar panels,
even washing machine imports sort.
Of course,
that is not all her at all.
Trump has already sat plans on the table
to implement many more tariffs really
soon.
The following will be set at the end of
August,
so check this out.
US unveils additional tariffs on $200
billion more in Chinese imports.
It's not going to question,
have you ever played monopoly or risk?
Well,
we could see that in the eyes of the
American president and this whole thing
is kind of like a board game and as he
is Donald Trump,
he's really not willing to lose hair
game.
Is Trump the game that game where you,
everything you ever wanted to own,
win or lose weight?
Yeah,
I think you'll like it.
Now we move onto the question.
Is it really going to be that simple?
Will the US presidents plans be
fulfilled and we'll via economy be
strengthened by this type of policy?
These aren't really the important
questions here for now.
We know the Donald Trump's speech is
beginning to make many American
multinationals very nervous.
I don't think this is going to get
resolved easily and I think these
terrorists are going to hurt the u s
economy.
Rufus York,
Sa President of the National Foreign
Trade Council,
which represents multinationals such as
Coca Cola,
Ford and Microsoft because fall from
what was promised,
the first victims are the American
people themselves.
This an op.
Okay,
broken dreams.
The Whitehouse repeatedly insists that
this new policy aims to boost US
companies.
However,
before trump supporters begin to
celebrate.
Just hold on a second because there are
some things that the president is not
taking into account.
The first is that the vast majority of
tariffs are being applied on
intermediate and capital goods.
That is goods that company important to
manufacture their products in the United
States.
Therefore,
one of two things is happening.
Either you pay the tariff or you start
buying in other markets,
even assuming that it's possible in the
United States itself.
In any case,
this implies a higher cost of
production,
which evidently reduces US companies
competitive.
Now,
this is,
for example,
the case of midcontinent nail that a
Missouri company that is the largest
producer of nails in the United States.
After trump approved tariffs on foreign
steel,
they had to lay off 60 of their 500
employees and everything points to it
being forced.
You close or transfer its entire
production to Mexico.
This is a company that works,
is a company that created employment
that was the competitive in the free
market and that now do you have to,
Washington's interference is falling
apart.
Then the second issue,
which I'm sure won't surprise any of you
peers that other countries,
I'm not just going to simply accepts
these tariffs and be like,
ah,
it's cool.
In order to defend the core interests of
the country and the interests of the
people,
we are forced to retaliate statement of
the Chinese Ministry of Commerce,
the European Union,
Canada and Mexico said that they will
respond to new US tariffs on steel.
Linda aluminum with punitive measures
targeting American products worth
billions of dollars.
These other countries,
they going to react and they're
basically going to say,
guys,
if you're going to set tariffs,
uh,
we're going to get on that too.
And this is something that just goes on
and on and it really shouldn't be like
that,
but it's simply is.
And really the consequences.
They don't take a long time to arrive.
Holly Davidson,
the popular motorcycle manufacturer and
one of the great icons in the U S and
check it out,
trump himself is actually a fan,
has now announced that it will transfer
parts of its production from its US
factories to new factories located in
Europe.
Okay.
You see,
when trump punish the European Union
with tariffs on steel and Alan Minium,
they responded with more tariffs of
their own.
For example,
they increased the tariff on imports of
motorcycles,
manufacturers in the United States from
6% to 31% so,
well,
what does this all mean?
Well,
on average,
that means about $2,200
extra for every motorcycle.
Some of it suggesting we should protect
American companies from foreign
competition.
I don't believe the American people are
afraid of competition.
That was made clear to me when I visited
a Harley Davidson plant recently.
When you hear talk about a tough trade
bill,
remember that being tough on trade and
commerce,
the of the economy,
one of the worst possible consequences
for the consumer and the American worker
as I told them at the Harley Davidson
plant,
it's time to gum.
The engine's not put on the brakes.
This is a cost which evidently European
motorcycle manufacturers such as BMW do
not have to face and thanks to a
commercial agreements between the
European Union and Japan.
Neither will a Yamaha Kawasaki or Honda,
which are by the way,
Harley Davidson's main competitors.
This is further proof of the harm from
unilateral tariffs.
The best way to help American workers,
consumers,
and manufacturers is to open new markets
for them,
not to raise barriers to our own market.
Ashley Strong a spokeswoman for House
Speaker Paul Ryan,
and as you might imagine taking donald
trump's character ncu accounts.
This news made him angry and the even
threatens the company itself by twitter.
Of course,
leave Davidson.
It should never be built in another
country.
Never.
Their employees and customers are
already very angry at them.
If they move,
watch,
it will be the beginning of the end.
They surrendered,
they quit.
The aura will be gone and they will be
taxed like never before.
President of the threatening and
damaging the image of a large American
companies simply for making business
decisions that could save them from
massive losses is completely bizarre,
but I suppose welcome to trump's America
now.
I suppose the question we could ask is
does that motorcycle company really
needs to transfer part of its production
over to Europe?
Harley Davidson need to look to the
world.
Yeah.
American companies have enough
challenges and problems to overcome as
it is without us having to deal with
interference and nonsense from the White
House.
You see,
trump's trade war has had a strong
impacts on companies like Harley
Davidson.
Their costs have increased due to steal
and Alan minium tariffs since,
but this means that the motorcycle
company is spending 20 million more
dollars every year,
and if that wasn't enough,
American multinationals are starting to
see the risk of them.
Market's closing.
Okay.
Creasing international production to
alleviate the EU tariffs burden.
He's not the company's preference,
but represents the only sustainable
option to make.
It's motorcycles accessible to customers
in the EU and maintain a viable business
in Europe.
Europe is a critical market for Harley
Davidson statement by Harley Davidson
because of this crisis has hard to the
motorcycle company at a time when it was
already pretty weak.
Checkout,
for example,
I'm its stock price has evolved over the
last four years.
Why did this happen?
Why did they see a huge 40% drop in
years when the US stock market has risen
like a rocket?
While the main explanation there via is
that times are changing was a time when
these big bikes,
these huge,
powerful,
noisy beast sweat something of a dream
for many Americans.
However,
due to the price,
they are very expensive and changing
tastes.
Today's generations aren't as attracted
to this type of motorcycle.
In fact,
the average age of holly earners in the
United States today is over 50 and
Zillow vis,
as you can imagine,
translates into the number of sales at
the company I'm making.
And therefore their profits in the last
three years alone,
the company's sales have decreased by
10% of profits of full length,
almost 40% and in 2018 things are even
worse.
Just a viewer is why this company,
they need to look abroad both to Europe
and Asia.
Because if there is no commercial
freedom and there are tariffs
production,
it just has to go to other places
because no Harley Davidson's decisions
got nothing to do with politics.
And of course it's not a betrayal.
It's simply an economic and
understandably logical decision made by
a company that simply has to compete.
Something by the way,
isn't easy now that they have to face
the consequences of the commercial war
that Washington has unleashed.
You know what?
This is not an isolated case.
Listen to this
multinationals,
drums,
lessees,
hom,
American companies,
and by extension the American economy.
And of course the further of the war
goes,
the greater the consequences will be.
Okay.
The moments American multinationals,
some of whipped supported trump park
getting very,
very nervous about this whole thing.
General Motors itself has said that if
the president finally approves tariffs
on vehicle importations,
it's something that the White House
raised recently.
The consequences would be less
investment,
that fewer jobs and fewer wages for
General Motors workers in the United
States.
Take for example,
the case of another us icon,
the Ford Mustang,
which of course is assembled in the
United States and exported from there to
the rest of it.
Yeah.
Well about 48% of the mustangs
components come from outside of the
United States,
so if those import south punished with
tariffs,
the result is a more expensive car,
both for American consumers as well as,
so we only have two
American Aniko Ford mustangs and Harley
Davidson's being negatively affected by
trump's policies.
It's not a good thing,
right?
America first America first,
and companies from other countries that
have factories in the United States such
as Toyota for your Chrysler,
Daimler and BMW.
A warning of the dangers of this war.
Mercedes Benz parent company.
Daimler warned that dueling tariffs
between the United States and China will
hit its earnings.
Specifically for SUV is made in Alabama,
but this isn't only effecting the
automotive industry,
it's virtually all sectors because yes,
it's true that the United States is the
largest economy on the planet has,
but do not forget that 85% of its GDP in
most of its growth happens outside its
borders.
Closing up,
it's simply bad for business.
Knitting barriers goes precisely against
the interests of a country that has
currently got a lot of employment,
is hitting record numbers in terms of
workers and has the largest industrial
production and its history.
Yeah,
I know Donald Trump talks a lot about
the trade deficits and yes,
there really is one,
but that's not for the reason that the
president's states,
you see the United States,
it doesn't have a trade deficit because
it's being robust,
not at all.
In fact,
it's simply got it because this is an
economy that consumes more than it
produces.
If Donald Trump wants to reduce the
deficits,
he can't.
For example,
stop the immense public spending that is
causing so many problems.
As we saw in this previous video,
you can also promote savings and
investments,
so the companies are more productive
among many,
many other things.
And the overall reality is,
is that this trade war is kind of bad
for everyone,
but now it's your turn.
What do you think about the trade war?
Do you support it d and not?
Well,
leave your answer in the comments below
as well as in this survey and I really
hope you enjoyed this video.
Please do hit that like button if you
did.
And don't forget to subscribe to our
channel for brand new videos.
Also,
do not forget to check out our friends
at the reconsider media podcast.
They provide us the vocals in this
episode,
though we're not mine,
and as always,
thank you for watching
leader of another country,
which is awesome.
They always stop my shake.
Sir,
I'd like to congratulate you on the
incredible job you've done with the
United States.